make sure you grab yourself a membership
at
joinpackman.com you'll get access to the
award-winning bonus show these are all
awards we've created but they are awards
also you'll get commercial free audio
and video streams of the show you can
sign up at joinpacman.com
let's get back to the phones after a
multi-week hiatus
due to various federal holidays and
different things and reasons and all of
that sort of stuff we now do calls via
discord davidpakman.com
slash discord
let's start today with i i can't see
is it kendall from is it san marino or
somewhere in california kendall
actually it's uh san marcos texas san
marcos day okay that's still allowed
that's okay
um yeah hey david so my question is
i have a friend who identifies as a
conservative republican okay but she's
not she's not like
those though nowadays republicans who
are very cult-like and all that stuff
and i can have i can have meaningful
conversations with her and when i
introduced her to my sister afterward
after my friend had left my sister who
was very liberal told me to stop being
friends with her
solely based on the fact she is a
conservative republican
how would i how do you think i should
handle that situation because i don't
want to make my friend mad and lose my
friend but i also don't want to piss off
my sister who's been my best friend
forever well so let's i mean the devil
is in the details really do they do your
sister and your friend live in close
proximity to each other where you would
be seeing them together
uh yeah especially recently i'm
graduating uh i'm graduating from texas
state uh university soon and there's
going to be a lot of upcoming events
where both of them are going to be
in close proximity well i think you need
to decide
do you want to go to your sister and
just have a conversation and say listen
sis i love you i want to have a
relationship with you i also have i'm an
adult i have other friends
and this is not some you know disgusting
immoral person it's just kind of i'm
hearing from you this is just kind of
like a
you know basic conservative and i find
her to be a good person good enough for
me to be friends i want all of us to be
able to be adults here and and see what
the reaction is the other possibility
would be to accept maybe cutting off one
or the other which i don't particularly
recommend i don't think it's at the
point where that needs to happen but
it's up to you to determine how far you
want to go with this you know i can't
it's hard for me to tell you
okay
i just wanted i just wanted some advice
from uh someone who whose whole job is
politics yeah i mean i would my instinct
not knowing nearly enough about you or
your friend or your sister or the
dynamic would be
to go to your sister and just be very
frank and be like listen if this was
some lunatic racist
trumpist whatever
i wouldn't be friends with them and you
should be doing an intervention if i
were but that's not what this is this is
just someone who's kind of like your
milktoast conservative and we don't
agree on things but
uh this is still a friend of mine and i
want us to all be able to be together
and uh i hope that you would respect
that as my sister and see where it goes
that's my that would be my first step
okay well thank you so much david my
pleasure good let us know how it goes
okay kendall
i will you have a good day all right
there is kendall
from texas what a situation
let's go next to isa from london isa you
were on the air
hey david how you doing i'm doing well
um cool cool um uh you may have seen
this did you see the uh louisiana judge
who was
uh came under fire because she was
caught uh using racial slurs on her home
camera and then she ended up resigning i
did see it yeah
um i wanted to i want to ask i feel like
you know looking
into the uk into the u.s sorry from the
outside i feel like
it's kind of a simulation to the point
where
would it be crazy to think that she
might run for some kind of local
political office now
no i mean you know obviously their
narrative is she's been canceled you
know she wow she was caught saying
something in the privacy of her own home
and now it's been used to
force her into resigning you know the
truth is as a judge
you regularly have to make
a decisions that are critical
life-altering decisions for people that
come before you in the court
and if there is any reason to believe
that on racial grounds you might be
assigning different sentences or
evaluating cases evidence differently
emotions
that's a major major problem you know
you could
i would stipulate
that there are some jobs where you might
be a lunatic racist and it really might
not make a difference you know if you
work in uh
i don't even know if you i don't want to
diminish any any profession but if it's
a profession where you kind of work by
yourself if you work in meat processing
and your job is to you know scale salmon
or something like that and you basically
work by yourself on the production line
you're and you're a lunatic racist yeah
it might be hard to relate to the
workers that are of a different race but
it's not like part of your job if you're
scaling salmon if that makes sense
whereas if you're a judge this is your
beliefs about race are so important now
you could make the case well despite
using the racial slurs she's not
actually racist but
you're in a position where the stakes
are really really high so but to your
point despite it being completely
reasonable what took place yeah she
might be the type of person that's made
a hero by the right and ends up running
for public office
yeah yeah no
100 i completely agree with what you
said about the uh you know uh if you
have some other kind of job but i feel
like stuff like this has happened in the
past and it's kind of
led these people to snap and kind of tip
them over the edge and then they become
like full blown right wing but um yes i
was thinking even if if she did run for
office she could probably base like her
whole campaign i guess
around her first amendment or free
speech rights being violated or whatever
you know 100 you you you have your
finger on the pulse of the culture wars
for sure that could be her entire
candidacy i was canceled but i'm back
yeah yeah no exactly
hey look even if she doesn't want for
office
you know maybe
700k a year drop a fox as an analyst or
something about how the election was
stolen no that'll be cushy that'll be
cushy for sure hey listen how are things
in london with omicron
oh yeah it's raging it's raging man
definitely have you had
no i've fortunately i i mean i've done
uh
all the tests i've done come back
negative but
uh the
daily
sort of i guess new cases show up to
about 200k that's the highest ever been
the deaths haven't been rising too much
kind of been at this the same level yeah
between 100 and 200 a day but yeah cases
cases have shown up definitely is the
hope there as it is here that this way
wave will come and go with many cases
but relatively few deaths and then maybe
we can move on
well yeah definitely yeah yeah yeah 100
but the thing is uh that we haven't
really had any restrictions either right
and um you know i i work at university i
work in research and i got an email
today saying
you know we want to try and maximize
in-person
campus teaching campus work and whatnot
so yep kind of just getting on with it
really yeah
all right well very good are our chip
shops mostly still open
uh yes they are okay and uh the fish is
still fresh and everything oh yeah it's
frying it's frying beautiful beautiful
all right issa thank you for the call
all right thanks david all right very
powerful testimony there as to the
situation with fish and chips in london
it's
a critical critical issue let's go next
to yusuf from our friendly neighbors to
the north in toronto canada yusuf you
were on the air
question it's slightly tongue-in-cheek
but also slightly serious um
oh you cut out right when we were gonna
get to the question i can tell your
connection is extremely shaky let's see
if we can back it up just a little bit
and take the question from the top
and he's gone
uh that's too bad i was looking forward
to hearing from yusuf let's go next to
tom from green bay wisconsin green bay
wisconsin welcome tom
tom from green bay you're on the air if
you unmute you will be able to talk to
me and i would love that
all right
tom from green bay i can see that you
are muted i've unmuted you but you are
you are self-muting if you unmute i will
be able to talk to you otherwise we will
have to move on
all right that's too bad i mean it's
like i can see that tom has not unmuted
which is sad let's try jamie from canada
jamie from canada you're on the air
hello
happy new year david thank you and we're
not on speakerphone are we
uh no we're not okay good it sounds like
we are but you can go ahead okay
oh wait uh
how does that sound does that sound
better it it sounds so much better i
can't even imagine what you were doing
before
oh i i i have this weird thing where i
need to plug in the usb microphone to my
laptop oh okay all right well go ahead
what's on your mind
uh i was wondering
you've probably been asked this question
before but why don't you ever run for
house or senate um that's the first part
of my question you know i have had
conversations with political consultants
about possible house seats to target and
i'm just not sure it's something i want
to do to be perfectly frank i don't know
that i could i i just don't know that
it's for me i don't know that i like the
idea of having to split time between
home and dc
i don't know that i want the kind of
financial oversight that's required for
like everything you do i i just am not
sure but when people have asked me i
i've not i've not ruled out anything but
for now there's not been a particular
seat that i've decided to target
uh okay um are you comfortable saying
what state you're in or is that personal
well at the time that these were
discussions it would have been
massachusetts
oh okay yeah
understandable also um second part of my
question i had this conversation with my
friends
uh back when the back in like at the
beginning of the year when the political
climb but was still like recovering now
hold on do you do you mean the beginning
of last year because it were five days
the beginning of 2021
beginning of 2021 that's what i meant
got it sorry i'm still trying to get
used to saying no i know last year yeah
yeah um to start at the beginning of
2021 around maybe march
um
we were talking after we were still
recovering from trump i i i mean i live
in canada and i was still like
traumatized by the election yeah um but
um
so we were talking about if not trump
who else because people are saying oh
trump could pick ron desantis instead of
using pence again because at that time
he was saying that pence had betrayed
him
multiple air quotes um but
we were also thinking about like uh we
were having this discussion on another
server and we were also thinking about
like maybe
nikki hate we were we were doing fantasy
pairing like nikki haley with marjorie
taylor green or something like that yeah
but yeah if not trump
who do you think
right now based on the polling i've seen
the only person who has a real shot is
ron desantis being the nominee
now it's we haven't even had the 2022
midterms yet anything could happen trump
could be dead by then everything could
completely change so i don't know but in
the polling i've seen
right now if it's if trump doesn't want
it and it seems trump would win a
primary
it would be desantis as the as the kind
of second second person which i think is
really scary because desantis is as much
trump as trump but less incompetent and
i think that that makes him more
dangerous
ah thank you but
it would also be
uh it'd also be interesting to see if he
ends up picking if it is trump the front
rudder if he ends up picking ron
desantis as his running mate that would
be i think that would be interesting it
would be fascinating i don't think trump
will do it and the reason why is over
the last six to nine months as we've
been covering there seems to be
increasing anger
from trump towards desantis that
desantis is getting attention so i
actually think for ego reasons trump
would not pick desantis
i have no idea how to say i just got
re-elected it was like less than a point
yeah that last gubernatorial election
well he's up this year i believe right
so let's see what happens
yeah
hopefully and i and people are calling
me crazy but i think beta or rourke's
got it uh if if the if the tide change
is just a teeny little bit and by people
are saying that i'm going to take away
your guns come it makes them unelectable
that's what people are saying i i am
concerned about that comment i'm
concerned about that okay well
thank you so much okay good year david
thank you so much likewise there's jamie
from canada getting a bunch of important
issues
right on the table and very very quickly
i must say
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman